I just think it sets the sport back if
you've been a fan you're like God this
is stupid if you're a new fan you're
kind of like oh this is so barbaric this
is stupid it just sets the sport back
that they've worked how long how many
years has the UFC UFC brass and the
staff that's been there for years and
the five is involved who've literally
risked their health their well-being
their brains they've moved their sport
how far down the field and then to
Market to this slot fighting it goes all
the way back these politicians or the
other people are just getting the sport
go oh my God that's they're just
slapping each other just big out of
shape dudes slapping each other yeah so
all this work you've done this just
proves to me we're not a major sport
we're not a top five major sport if
you've done all this work to move the
football down the field and then you go
all the way back and restart